at est à l'achat sur les perdre ici on
est 2 septembre et que la chasse à la
rascasse heures et tout et tu viens de
chasse et pêche mondiale d'énergie les
acheter de perdrix offert et ben je suis
allé en irak est bien ouais à lundi
c'était la rentrée des classes mais
apparemment dans nos émissions préférées
y en a qui ont redoublé alors on sort
son style aux quatre couleurs et une
copie doute parce que c'est l'heure de
nietzsche à g r oui quand même
c'est parti pour le moment les garçons
ne vous font pas de cadeaux ils sont
très pointilleux et ne laisse rien
passer
faut arrêter de jouer les filets les
frères audrey graphiste et en
confinement dans quinze jours on a eu
des prises de sang des tests chazal non
pour moi ce
tu rentres tu veux trop professoral et
chéri e
on a dû chira michou veux tu vas bientôt
une tarte au citron
non mais quand même très fort on
essaiera traite en dessert le trophy
terol c'est mon dessin apprécié non plus
en profiter mais relevant qu'une part tu
m'invites au restaurant tu me ferais un
profit tenir un dandy couple parfait et
à sède et brian et c'est brian et son
frère du coup quand seb dit un truc à
brian il peut lui faire confiance ça
s'appelle la solidarité entre frères ça
c'est parce que sa fille lisa personnage
dans le bénéfice en fait moyenne un
genre hier marc sanchez
[Musique]
donc là je sais que quand mon frère et
mon dit un truc comme ça hyper
confidentiel moi ça je dis rien hyper
confidentiel inquiète c'est dans la
boîte cher il dira rien c'est hyper
confidentielles et ne dira rien mais
cette fois c'est vrai cet indice est
tombé hier
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai fait une vraie
boulette vraiment quand on est d'accord
c'est moi j'ai rien dit c'est un cas
dire si vous aviez à secret a confié à
qui vous fait le plus confiance
ici autour de la table je vous dire à
qui je confierai mon secret raymond en
quoi ce serait qui si je dois confesser
un secret tu veux te rendormir je te
rappelle à tous ma taille rebelles
avaient ensuite abonnements à toi c'est
vrai surtout pas mais bon c'est mon
frère abbas
parce que c'est qui dira pas bah oui ce
serait quoi genre comme secret
[Rires]
janvier sera cammalleri à valérie sera
qui a child in kelly jamie t mon kelly
pas moi bah ouais c'est ça vous fait
plaisir mais tokyo kalou j'espère que
vous allez l'attaqué quand benjamin à
oui j'aimerais faudra pas que ce soit un
secret visuel direct valérie away
benjamin mais c'est vrai vous bah merci
aux examens bah oui je c'est bon aussi
cessé
vous vous êtes des petits secrets qu'il
faut pas de confier quelques étoiles
gilles g pr gilles parce que j'ai bien
vu en coulisses que personne lui parler
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
est ce que toutes les vérités sont
bonnes à et d'autre chose demandez
toujours dans la même émission donc je
coupais par c c'est ça toujours dans la
même émission on a vu en avant première
la bande annonce du futur blockbuster
qui risque bien de détrôner avatar au
box-office pour reprendre les mots de
télérama un thriller attend qui déchire
sa mère
plus ma jalousie est un vilain défaut
pays et si quelqu'un était prête à tout
pour en acquérir une mèche
j'ai une mèche prochainement sur vos
écrans mais je m'attendais pas du tout à
ça alors il est fort et l'effort elle a
pu montrer tout est alors une me cracher
dessus mais bon sinon des dons vous
inquiétez pas de souris la plus de
salive au quadrillage pour une lune de
miel et on a vu un gâteau digne du
meilleur pâtissier
le problème c'était pas le gâteau mais
c'était plutôt ce qui avait marqué
dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
julie powell laisse le mariage en
anglais ça se dit weeding attention ne
pas confondre avec la weed
j'ai un peu différent vous l'avez
rappeuse jamais fumé un joint entre
comme ça jamais thérapeutique et wii la
wii wii la wii louis s'élève à 8 tout
l'été mais là il m'a pris de la weed
tout l'été nocture goal quoi savez ce
que c'est le web de l'herbe j'imagine je
crois c'est son bel et bien oui pas
alors on va toujours dire aux
spécialistes bien sûr benjaouid c'est
l'herbe en anglais seront pas trop
serrer une question vous avez des
nouvelles de king l'eau comme nous alors
je n'ai pas eu au téléphone cette année
hamadé prochaine et que tu as entre deux
lectures du dictionnaire notre chère
amie kim a encore frappé fort de la
culture générale par ci de la culture
générale par là vous allez voir einstein
n'a qu'à bien se tenir
[Musique]
c'est pas volé personne savait ça c'est
très fort et à frankenstein c'est
magique et c'est une des meilleures
gbagbo est mort de rire
on va partir et 12 coups ni ça c'est ça
les 12 coups de midi on a fait la
connaissance de me faire ma fait la
connaissance d'antonio alors anthony lui
ce qu'il aime pas dans la vie c'est
répondre aux questions du coup dans une
émission où le but c'est répondre aux
questions ça tombe mal
ah c'est sûr qu'elle taxe béton quand on
possède un téléviseur passé la redevance
audiovisuelle
quelle figure de la télévision française
et la mère d'antoine de caunes
je sais plus jacqueline et joubert quel
nom porte le [ __ ] laveur dont les
gardiens de la galaxie raccoon selon
l'expression qu'est ce qui saute pour
annoncer la fin de quelque chose
le gong le q quelle capitale du sud est
asiatique que ça peut l'être
autrefois batavia je sais pas car tu as
qu'appelle-t-on de façon poétique et la
voûte céleste partiel qu'elle h de
guerre étaient spécifiques offrant
l'arbalète la francisque
quel est le pays le plus petit
d'amérique centrale le panama le sol
dans quel film se fait sur clavier
dit-il merci la gueuse tuer l aideront
et à vos visiteurs pensent qu'il est
trop tard pendant que jean luc reichmann
faisait comme on essaie de jouer un
revêtement quand on est dedans y'a rien
à dire et ça cartonne toujours un
clément way toujours une moitié payée au
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
modestement j'avais toujours cru que je
pourrais peut-être avoir un petit
ouverture et kelly j'ai appris tout à
l'heure qu'elle préférait mag les skis
si elle préfère le dentifrice aux
fenêtres saison nouvel animateur prendre
à l'essai allez faites vous des bisous
j'adore ces gens bien passé c'est très
drôle par contre il est drôle ah ouais
mais en plus j'ai vu que du coup oui
toujours cartonne alors tu peux rejouer
là c'est bon oui puisque maintenant il
ya les rassemblements de plus de cinq
personnes sont autorisées dans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
septembre à rouen jusqu'à la semaine
prochaine entre octobre et
universellement pertes à chauvigny très
vite envoyé bah oui le 7 octobre c'est
martine aubry janvier à bordeaux 3 6 1
mais tant que je suis en ville et à
paris oui ça paraît tout je m'en serais
alors tu vas seul pato d'apprendre au
lycée si je me dis oui il est tout de
suite à quoi d'autres mines tout de
suite avec 90 minutes enquête qui
proposait une émission spéciale braquage
et courses-poursuites away immersion
avec les superflics de belgique
mais entre braquage et courses
poursuites les superficies grèce tombe
parfois sur des énigmes qui sont pas si
simples que ça à résoudre 21h31 dont
quelques minutes avant qu'ils prennent
la fuite
et il a mis à les bikers et l'onu répond
environ une heure après à éviter ppp
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir
dire
fruit de la passion puis les pêches fans
de pokémon or et des films de plus gros
la machine est tellement mignon regarder
winamax
[Musique]
est trop mignon
on les sent vraiment qu'il a fallu du
temps mais en fait il ya bien marqué
hier aussi il y avait une mer bien relou
et pas vu qu'il n'a pas vu ça la mer
vous vous n'avez sans doute pas cet
extrait en régie s'il vous plaît à ça
mais regardez face et me bruno le maire
dauphin de sebou j'en ai fait mais on ne
sait rien mais qui était très drôle où
il a marqué le maire du village veut
essayer de parler au forcené
mais ce n'est pas du tout du goût du
major il est passé par tours à faire là
bas n'est pas légal la gendarmerie
nationales éventuellement avec
l'adjudant-chef la non ok mais pas avec
moi
allez-y n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
je connais le gars je voulais montrer
que j'étais montrer vraiment ce que
c'est que le mot vie c'est d'être drôle
d'être drôle c'est le pouvoir des
pouvoirs extraordinaires du coroner
celles qui font des petits prés
génériques et ça me rappelle les prix
générique de france 4 de tpm p vraiment
je pense que ce sont les mêmes auteurs
vous savez je suis pas solide en ce
moment j'aurai besoin de manger
tiens on s'en doute ou quoi ça doit être
la normale lui a cédé un truc je suis
chaud comme la braise que tu vois pas
imaginer comment la libye tôt c'est
aussi une affaire de remarque surtout
qu'est ce que tu as à me parler dorment
là en permanence là bas qu'est ce qu'il
a il nous fait une petite crise de nerfs
hélas les hormones hop la fin
non pas se mettre à pleurer comme un si
tu veux on raccroche et on part en
voyage on va essayer de comprendre à
quoi servent les hormones et comment ça
marche allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]